hasta hace unas semanas fui productora y
actriz de un proyecto que tiene una gran
importancia en mi carrera no solamente
por el valor artístico de este proyecto
sino porque lo engendró como una manera
de decir fernanda quiere decirle esto al
mundo pero porque importa lo que
fernanda castillo quiere decirle al
mundo quién soy yo que vos tengo porque
les va a importar a ustedes lo que yo
quiera decir
hace unos días como decía manuel llegué
al aeropuerto era la una de la mañana
así que estaba yo como más dormida que
despierta la verdad
llegó me acerco con la señorita que
estaba en el mostrador
me estoy durmiendo un poco en el
mostrador mientras le doy mis papeles y
escucho que me dice te ha costado mucho
llegar a dónde estás
yo la verdad es que estaba pensando en
el segundo vuelo que tomas en 24 horas
tienes miedo de que no te entre el
vestido ahora que llegue esa nueva york
no has comido no has dormido y yo que
suelo ser muy platicador a nada más le
contesté si me ha costado mucho
y entonces me dicen
pero vale la pena no lo disfrutas porque
yo estoy detrás de este mostrador y odio
lo que hago siempre quise estudiar artes
escénicas pero me da mucho miedo morirme
de hambre
y entonces sus palabras me despertaron
la verdad dije
y coraje que me estoy quejando dentro de
mí sin valorar que yo puedo hacer lo que
más me gusta en la vida como tal vez
muchos de aquí y que muchas otras
personas no pueden así que sin pensar le
contesté yo muchas veces en esta carrera
no tuve para pagar la renta y hoy me
aplaudo porque no me deje vencer por los
obstáculos que me puso así que vence ese
miedo salte de aquí y haz lo que más te
gusta porque aún si te mueres de hambre
vas a estarlo disfrutando de alguna
manera
me agradeció me entregó mis papeles me
sonrió yo me fui muy orgullosa de
haberle dicho lo que pensaba y me pasé
las siguientes cinco horas de vuelo
diciendo en la madre y si ya le perdió
la vida esta mujer
y si me hace caso de verdad
bueno igual y no no nadie cambia su vida
por lo que le diga a cualquiera en un
aeropuerto a la una de la mañana
pero después pensé si ella me compartió
algo tan cercano tal vez para ella no
soy cualquiera tal vez para ella soy
mónica robles entonces tal vez si le
importa no
y entonces me di cuenta que tengo voz
tengo voz porque soy escuchada
y que [ __ ] miedo la verdad
qué enorme responsabilidad es esa
los seres humanos siempre han buscado el
arte para identificarse no es
coincidencia que el arte haya acompañado
a las grandes revoluciones y movimientos
sociales de todas las épocas de todos
los países siempre ha habido artistas
que no se conforman con ver nada más
desde lejos y decir lo que les dijeron
que tenían que decir o pensar lo que les
dijeron que tenían que pensar y más bien
piensan lo que quieren lo ponen en su
arte
aun si va a encontrar el sistema no les
importa
y entonces tocan al mundo en todas las
épocas estoy hablando de artistas como
víctor hugo escribiendo los miserables
como garcía lorca en españa- como émile
zola
y artistas como pablo neruda en su
poesía
y pintores como pablo picasso a la hora
de hacer el guernica
como diego rivera en su mural del
rockefeller center
estoy hablando de músicos como john
lennon como joan baez como pablo milanés
como silvio rodríguez
[Música]
músicos actuales como bebé que hablaba
de la violencia contra las mujeres en
sus canciones como calle 13 que no los
que haya nadie
como ping que de repente escribe una
canción a bus cuestionándole porque
manda a los soldados a la guerra que si
puede dormir con eso estos artistas
rebeldes siempre han existido
son esos artistas que se comprometen con
sus ideas las defienden y tocan el mundo
al que pertenecen porque yo
yo influyó yo soy de alguna manera un
educador de la sociedad sea consciente o
no
porque yo con lo que hago con como actuó
con lo que pienso
y yo a la gente que me admira aunque no
sea mi propósito
que [ __ ] miedo otra vez no porque
puedo yo estar tocando vidas y estar
comiendo camote y ni siquiera enterarme
estar en la tonta y estoy tocando vidas
así que si tengo voz y soy escuchada más
vale que diga algo que valga la pena y
que cambie la vida de alguien mientras
estaba preparando esta conferencia me
encontré con un post que la verdad es
que fue muy doloroso leerlo pero creo
que tiene mucha verdad y me gustaría
compartirlo con ustedes
lamentablemente la palabra
responsabilidad está out
hay mucho miedo a pensar pensar o sentir
críticamente está visto como un gesto
exagerado pronunciarse en contra de algo
es mala onda diría que reaccionar en
general está muy mal visto hoy ser cool
es que nada te afecte nada te importe
nada te tiene que parecer mal así
piensan los artistas jóvenes si algo te
parece mal estás juzgando estás tirando
la primera piedra entonces terminan
adoptando un comportamiento corporativo
políticamente correcto de lo más cobarde
y pasivo pero disfrazado de buena onda y
respeto a lo diferente
pero yo creo que los artistas no pueden
ser bohemios evadidos de la realidad
indiferentes a la realidad superfluos
todo lo contrario el artista tiene que
ser un mensajero de la realidad y algo
para asustarse más es un mensaje también
lo que quiero decir con esto es que no
solo influimos en la gente que ve
nuestros personajes o nuestros proyectos
de la carrera de actor también influimos
con nuestro actuar y nuestro pensar en
la gente
qué horror yo creo que esto estaba en
las letras chiquitas del contrato de yo
quiero ser artista que muchos artistas
que yo conozco firmaron porque ni
siquiera se han dado cuenta
yo desde muy chica sabía de esta misión
sé que tengo la responsabilidad de como
persona pública y como actriz formar
parte de los movimientos sociales de mi
país porque si yo marcho exigiendo
respuestas al lado de los padres de la
guardería abc si yo cuestiono al
gobierno entonces la gente que me sigue
sabe que me importa y sabe algo más
importante aún que ellos también lo
pueden hacer que ellos también pueden
cuestionar si yo ejerzo mi libertad de
expresión en mis redes sociales si apoyo
a las minorías si comparto con el
público que me sigue mis fracasos y mis
defectos entonces le estoy dando una
lección de valentía a la gente que me
admira
así mismo trato de hacerlo con no
solamente como personas sino también en
los proyectos que hago
yo pienso que los personajes te eligen
de una manera metafísica no por el
casting sino eligen quién los va a
representar para que seas el bueno que
va a dar un mensaje importante y ocho
personajes de mujeres buenas y no tan
buenas de hecho una daniela montalvo en
destilando amor que defendía a su novio
que tenía la piel negra de la
discriminación de su familia he hecho
una mujer completamente inocente e
insegura entereza haciendo luisa de la
barrera
he hecho una mujer comprometida con el
amor y con la amistad en el musical 'hoy
no me puedo levantar' en la movida en la
movida madrileña
he hecho un personaje como elisa que es
una mujer que se da cuenta del valor de
la vida cuando empieza a luchar contra
el cáncer y le agradezco a todos estos
personajes que hayan pasado por mi
carrera pero es hasta hace cuatro años
que de repente aparece un personaje en
mi vida que se vuelve un riesgo y un
riesgo porque interpretar a mónica
robles
es una narcotraficante me quiere
explicar que conciencia social puede
parecer es a la gente en general me
cuestiona pero están invitando a los
jóvenes a hacer de narcotraficantes y el
interpretar este personaje
ella me reta a mí
a decir no me puedo quedar con la idea
de es narcotraficante igual es mala
tengo que decir esta mujer el resultado
del mundo donde creció es una mujer que
toma decisiones y vive las consecuencias
de ellas y si no queremos más mónica
robles o no queremos más
narcotraficantes lo que tenemos es
cambiar el mundo donde crecen nuestros
niños para que no crezcan personas así y
entonces no exista el narcotráfico y no
exista la corrupción del gobierno es
desde los cimientos porque tengo que
hacer este personaje como un ser humano
que todos podamos entender y este
personaje me conecta con la audiencia de
otra manera
mónica robles se vuelve un icono de
fortaleza en las redes sociales para las
mujeres pero no solamente como una
figura feminista sino es una figura de
no bajó la cabeza ante ningún obstáculo
de la vida para hombres y para mujeres
y es después de las bendiciones que me
trae este personaje que un día paró en
seco y digo
están pasando cosas padrísimas tengo que
regresar esa luz
y entonces creo
no lo cree yo de alguna manera porque
alguien más describió jorge hace un un
dramaturgo y director argentino
wake of woman ahí es donde nace
este proyecto es una obra de teatro que
trata sobre la violencia de género que
desgraciadamente es un tema tabú muchas
veces porque nos han acostumbrado a que
nos dé vergüenza hablar de él y solo lo
escuchamos en las noticias
habla de natalia y federico dos
personajes que se aman profundamente
tienen una historia de amor y terminan
en una relación de destrucción
donde nos cuestiona esta obra porque
amamos como amamos porque no hemos
aprendido a amar bien porque las
historias de violencia nunca empiezan
con hola qué tal mucho gusto cachetadón
no siempre empiezan con amor siempre
empiezan con encanto y después sale lo
que la gente tiene guardada
y es en esta embarcados en este viaje de
hacer hueco pullman que yo y mi
compañero productor erik hayser además
para poner la más difícil es mi pareja
también en la vida real entonces los los
trancazos iban con mi pareja real en el
escenario que estábamos muy
comprometidos con decir tenemos que
decirle a la gente que tiene que pensar
en la violencia desde sus casas desde su
vida desde ellos mismos
wake of woman fue un proyecto lleno de
violencia de sacrificio y de dolor
dentro del escenario y les puedo
asegurar que casi fue igual de
sacrificio y de doloroso hacerlo
fuera del escenario
pero no hubo una sola función en la que
eric y yo nos hubiéramos a ese escenario
y no dejáramos el alma y el cuerpo
porque teníamos el compromiso con el
público de decir tal vez en esta función
alguien ahí esté sentado que esté
pasando por una situación de violencia y
tal vez vea esta obra y se cuestione y
tal vez una mujer diga nunca más me van
a volver a violentar o una madre pueda
traer a sus hijos como sucedió a
decirles mira como pasan las situaciones
de violencia de enojo a la hora de
relacionarte
y creo que este este proyecto se vuelto
tan importante para mí porque creo que
la gente que lo vio dejó una huella
inmensa
para mi artista
es aquel que sirve un propósito más
grande aquel que tiene una misión que
con lo que hace toca a los otros los
despierta hace conciencia aquel que
desde su trinchera cambia el mundo
artista es una palabra muy grande yo la
verdad es que todos los días
lucho y sigo persiguiendo el honor de
llamarme artista como
como lo soñé cuando era una niña y para
finalizar me gustaría compartir con
ustedes una anécdota que que siempre me
recuerda que los niños son muy sabios yo
era muy sabio en esa época después quién
sabe que me pasó
y que siempre ha tenido clara esta
misión
cuando yo era niña mis papás se
divorciaron a los 8 años y creo que yo
nunca fui consciente de la angustia y
del dolor inmenso y la tristeza que eso
me provocaba porque yo pensaba que tenía
que ser madura y apoyar a mis padres en
el proceso a los 8 años
gracias a dios mis padres si se
acordaban que yo tenía 8 años y dijeron
no tiene que ser madura nada yo creo que
le está doliendo un montón y vamos a
apoyar a la niña no y entonces juntaban
cada 15 días para llevarme al teatro que
era algo que yo disfrutaba mucho
en uno de los momentos más difíciles del
divorcio de mis padres
mi mamá me lleva al teatro y salgo de
esa obra donde tenía la gente muy cerca
los actores de los bailarines muy cerca
y salgo y le digo yo quiero hacer eso
mamá me dice que quieres bailar y actuar
en un escenario
y yo le digo no quiero hacer que a la
gente se le olvide que está triste
porque esa señora hizo que a mí se me
olvidara que ustedes se están
divorciando
si yo fernanda castillo con lo que hago
puedo hacer que alguien se le olvide su
dolor o sea consciente de él
si puedo cambiarle una idea o hacer que
se pregunte por qué pienso como pienso
porque siento como siento porque hago lo
que hago entonces estoy tocando su vida
y ese es mi compromiso y esa es la voz
que quiero tener muchas gracias
[Aplausos]